the fresh growth tips of spruce are
actually delicious we just realized we
don't have enough planks to finish the
roof finish by nightfall i'm rob
greenfield and i'm gonna help my friends
build a tiny house on their property in
just three days we're actually gonna do
the whole process from cutting down the
tree all the way to the finished tiny
house you might have seen me recently on
BuzzFeed when I finished a year-long
project of growing and foraging 100% of
my food this tiny house is going to be
fully off the grid and built completely
out of wood harvested on this property
as well as second-hand materials right
here from the farm
this is Antwon and Margo and we are at
La Rev de Gaia which means the dream of
Mother Earth why don't you tell us what
this place is
well I have the guy as an eco project
where we strive to be a community where
humans nature and animals can live in
productive harmony why we want a house
volunteers and people that want to know
about what we do here we need space to
host people and I'm the first volunteer
that's gonna live in this tiny house
right yeah shall we get to work no let's
build it the first thing that we need to
do is cut down a tree so that we have
wood to build the tiny house I've never
cut down a tree before you've cut down
thousands I'm a first so I'm gonna cut
some branches first so I have a bit more
space and then it's an easy tree because
it's a bit steep and it will fall nice
on the little field the reality is that
we're not actually using this tree
because we've already cut down some
trees six months ago yeah because they
need that dry a bit before they'd be
cutting planks but we wanted to start
with showing you the tree all the way to
the tiny house we've rotted over here on
the tractor now we changed the wood
because this route I think got that a
couple of months ago how many trees will
it take us to make this tiny house so
we're gonna need two three so now we're
gonna cut beams as
Foundation the floorboards beams for the
sides and then the planks to cover the
sides slash roofing all of these are
trees that were harvested from the land
he bought this land about seven years
ago and this has pine forests on it that
have been used for forestry for decades
now and a lot of it was done in a very
unsustainable way now he's transitioning
this into sustainable forestry and
moving it back into a native forests
that is a place for humans other species
and the environment to thrive and behind
me is his wood saw imagine if a
community had this they could come
together and build their houses out of
wood locally harvested and it would pay
for itself in no time creating jobs and
working with the land rather than having
things shipped and depending upon huge
corporations almost everything here is
stuff that we cut today it's wide almost
like four by fours these are for the
foundation these what we're calling
planks are for the roof slash sides are
the floorboards which you can see are
thicker so we're gonna send the
floorboards of the tiny house to prevent
splinters in your feet and we're gonna
only send the floor because we want to
keep the rest as natural as possible so
we probably cut half the wood today we
sanded the floor I'd say we're on
schedule okay it's the start of day two
overall we're off to a good start my go
is finished sanding the floorboards now
it's time to stain them and
antwuan is cutting planks to be the
right size how's it going good
we're gonna finish the wood with
flaxseed oil on therap and time so the
floorboards are smooth so you don't get
any splinters into your feet but the
floorboards are the only thing that
we're gonna finish like that because we
want to see how long a tiny house that
is used with natural materials were last
okay we've got most of the materials cut
we're already of over halfway into the
second day and I hope to be moving into
the tiny house in about 30 hours from
now I've always wanted a tree stump
table my dream is gonna come true
all right this is the spot right behind
me this is where we cut down the tree
yesterday and it's time to finally start
actually building this thing we're gonna
put we're gonna level it out so the
floor is straight it's not level so if
you lift it here a bit to keep the level
straight so we've actually moved the
foundation back a little bit so that we
didn't have to put it up as high and one
thing that I want to mention is on the
bottom we're using Douglas fir which is
more resistant to rot and will last
longer and then the rest of the housing
is spruce and I should mention this one
material that's not secondhand or from
the forest the screws cost about $30
altogether and this is pretty much the
main cost right screws first floor board
but uh how's it feel awesome solid yeah
I'm happy now we're putting on flooring
it's looking huge - all right so we have
a floor might even be able to sleep here
tonight a little bit hectic last couple
of days but I'm pretty hopeful alright
so we have the foundation set and
start moving upwards it's looking good
for moving in tonight so now we're
putting up the walls which is super
simple we're just taking these planks
and then we're just screwing them on and
they have an overlap keeps the rain
running down the side so a moisture
doesn't stay on there the windows and
doors cost zero dollars because they
were rescued from the landfill all right
it's four o'clock we just realized we
don't have enough clanks to finish the
roof this is the compost toilet I just
built we've got my raised bed garden
here and I've started a table so we are
putting in the last screws to have the
sides and the roof done if we finish the
structure we still wouldn't have
finished the inside
no not finished like the details no if
we continued tomorrow morning then we
can make it really good looking tiny
house right not moving in but tomorrow
we have just a little spot left up there
to do and once we've done that we'll
have built out the entire house itself
and still a little bit to do on the
inside but man three days was quite the
goal that would have been a serious
accomplishment voila
right now we've created the bed I've
wanted a stump table for a decade nice
tiny houses built
[Music]
but we did it have a good night so here
it is the tiny house built from trees
right on the land and over the next few
years probably hundreds of different
people will sleep inside of this tiny
house
so I want to give you a little bit of a
tour so come on inside it's really
designed to come here and live simply
and with the basics so there's the door
that I just walked through and then we
have one that goes right through the
back we built out a structure to put the
bed on top of and we're actually gonna
end up putting two beds inside of here
one on either side underneath the bed
there's some storage right above me
there's a shelf and then right over here
is a shelf as well just to have the
basic possessions and then this will be
made into a sitting area as well and
then here there'll be a flip-down desk
you don't live in the good life in here
and being able to spend most of the time
outside I'm gonna show you the kitchen
now and the idea with all of this is to
keep it sustainable so how this sink
works water we use is from the spring
and then instead of it going down the
drain it goes down and it's collected
into a bucket and then this water can be
put on to the garden to grow food with
using a biodegradable plant friendly
soap and it can go right on to the plans
the sink rescued from the landfill next
stop is the shower the water for the
shower comes from the spring as well or
harvesting rainwater and with this
bucket I just put holes in the bottom of
it and again this water stays right here
and just waters the trees so this is the
spring that's just about a 30-second
walk from the house delicious pure water
straight from the ground and this is the
water for showering and for doing the
dishes
it all comes from right here the compost
bin is very simple the idea of this is
to live as zero waste as possible to
compost everything that can be composted
and not send things to the landfill the
last stop on the Grand Tour is the
toilet and this is the pool or the view
we did have to buy the toilet seat which
was about $4 this plant is called Mullen
or lamb's ear and it's just a
wonderfully soft plant the toilet paper
grows right here for free in nature and
this is a compost toilet
so it's composted right here on site and
then that poop actually once it's
composted can be used to put on fruit
trees to grow fruit so here's my dream
table there's the stump from the tree we
cut down with a beautiful viewer just to
be able to sit here read relax
look out so there you have it from tree
to tiny house all together with the wood
coming from nature and using almost
everything else secondhand we spent
under $50 if you want to include the gas
and the wear and tear on the blade from
the saw then we're talking about maybe
another 30 or so dollars now I want to
say that this is designed just to be
used during the spring summer and fall
here in southern France and it's for
woofers or volunteers who are learning
organic farming here at loretta gaia i
hope that this video has been helpful in
realizing how simple it can be to build
a tiny house and i'll see you again real
soon
yeah that's good
you